vielleicht kennt ihr dieses Spielzeug
meine erste Erfahrung damit war beim
Zahnarzt im Wartezimmer und damit wird
die eigentlich eher ungeile Erfahrung
beim Zahnarzt ein bisschen weniger
Ungarn ich bin sogar gerne hingegangen
weil ich wusste da gibt's dieses Teil
früher konnte ich damit meinen gesamten
Handabdruck abdecken und naja die Jahre
vergehen und heute geht es eben nicht
mehr also dachte ich wir machen dieses
Teil einfach in Groß und wenn wir schon
dabei sind in richtig groß so groß dass
man einfach Abdrücke mit seinem ganzen
Körper machen kann dieses Video wird
unterstützt von Steuerbord mehr dazu
später es ist schon wieder viel zu früh
was war jetzt dein Plan also wie groß
soll das Teil sein so 2 m x 1 m du
Spielraum auf 1 Meter wenn ich bin schon
fast Meter breit
okay ich glaube 90 also mehr als 90 cm
so wie breit bist du von innen also
Meter gibt
drei oder vier Teilen
also machen wir 1 20 x 50 21 oder 60
passt ja perfekt
[Musik]
Ebene cool Glasscheibe brauchen
was fünf Stück brauchen
locker wir können das mal schauen aber
ich glaube brauchen locker 3000 oder so
oder vier
3000 Löcher kannst gleich noch mal einen
Satz Bohrer bestellen
okay also mindestens 33 mal 13 so
bräuchten wir halt einfach am Ende
trotzdem 1.7
nein das ist 12 mal 15 Moment
2000 Löcher geboren
150 kg
ja es hat einfach kein Baumarkt 150 Kilo
Nägel die haben alle dann irgendwie nur
so drei Packungen oder so wir bestellen
jetzt einfach die bei amazon.com Nägel
bis 500 Euro jetzt wo 2000 Nägel also
150 Kilogramm Stahl auf dem Weg zu uns
sind Rip an der Stelle einen Paketboten
der uns den Nägel liefern musste wird
der Rest des nagelbildes konstruiert
interessanterweise sieht das Ganze
ziemlich wie eine mittelalterliche
foltermaschine aus naja Manu und Pascal
sind dann losgezogen und haben alle
weiteren Materialien besorgen
wir haben Exemplar vor uns und man hat
gesagt dass man nie und immer den Nagel
irgendwo in Holz reinhauen kann ohne
dass das Holz komplett spaltet bist du
auch gehört Schatz
so
nach ey
das geht richtig gut
und damit sind wir durch es ist schon
geil also ist schon mächtiger Nagel und
das Holz macht es auch easy mit das
Problem von diesen Nägeln ist dass sie
jetzt natürlich ultra Spitze nicht mehr
machen natürlich immer Sinn aber wir
wollen uns ja irgendwann ganzen Körper
dagegen drücken damit man den auf den
Nagelbild sieht so wäre das ja auch
schon eine Idee die Idee beinhaltet
Schrumpfschläuche die sind eigentlich
zum Isolieren von Kabeln ja aber die
Kamera auf die Spitze drauf stecken und
dann heißt es machen
und dann ist das einmal nicht mehr so
spitz und da kann man sich dann locker
dagegen drücken ich mache jetzt meinen
kleinen Prototyp dafür muss ich dazu
schneiden schaut das auf jeden Fall an
Mann und der hier eine richtig fette
Absaugung für die Kappsäge und alle
anderen Maschin gemacht hat
oh da bekommt man eigentlich unsere
Nägel benutzen
du kannst auch bleiben
[Musik]
mal 7,5 mm für 7 mm dicken Nagel
also man kriegt schon Gespür dafür wie
sich das Gewicht hinten wird weil jeder
von diesen Nägeln liegt irgendwie so 60
70 Gramm
jetzt gibt es hier Heißluft für den
Action das haben wir aber später noch
eine größeren ja mit denen dauert es
dann doch ein bisschen lang
[Musik]
mindestens genauso schmerzhaft wie diese
Nägel ist es bei jeder Gehaltsabrechnung
zu sehen wie sich ungefähr die Hälfte
vom Gehalt in Luft auflöst aber es gibt
ein Licht am Ende des Tunnels denn
Steuerbord der spons des heutigen Videos
hat es sich zum Ziel gemacht euch dabei
zu helfen möglichst viel Geld mit einer
Steuererklärung vom Staat zurückzuholen
so unkompliziert und schnell wie möglich
[Musik]
alles wird komplett papierlos einfach
per Chat erledigt und durch dieses Chat
Layout macht das Ganze sogar fast ein
bisschen Spaß in der Regel dauert die
Steuererklärung 120 Minuten bist du
fertig und damit bereits zu Übermittlung
zum Finanzamt ist aber natürlich erspart
euch Steuerbord damit nicht nur eine
Menge Zeit sondern den Durchschnitt
bekommt er damit auch 1.95 €
zurückerstattet weil sie sowas noch nie
gemacht hat dürft ihr euch interessieren
dass das sogar vier Jahre Rückwirkung
funktioniert bei einer Rückerstattung
von weniger als 100 € kostenlos und über
100 € zahlt ihr nur 29,95 € einfach von
den mindestens 100 erstatteten Euro
abgezogen werden den Link zur Steuerbord
findet ihr in der Videobeschreibung mit
10 € extra also holt euch euer Geld vom
Staat zurück und wenn ihr wollt auch
über diesen aber das ist natürlich noch
viel zu klein und jetzt den ganzen
Körper abzubilden
deshalb wird das ganze Teil jetzt ein
riesig gebaut
[Musik]
richtig geil
geworden
3400 Löcher insgesamt sind wusstest du
dass es zwei Arbeitstag ja danke auf
jeden Fall stark
gebracht aus den beiden
Lochplatten basteln wir jetzt quasi
schon mal das erste Modul
[Musik]
und wenn Manu und ich fleißig dabei sind
die Module zusammen zu schrauben sind
tatsächlich die Nägel angekommen
Gewicht 25 kg drauf mal schauen ob der
jetzt
sich gar nichts
nice wir wollen wir das machen hinlegen
so und dann länger aber erstmal zwei
oder alle direkt
weil das jetzt aktuell noch ziemlich
durchblickt haben wir uns das so
entschlossen noch so ein ja Brett
reinzumachen dass das ein bisschen
stabilisiert und da kommt jetzt auch
wieder direkt noch mal die geile Nägel
ganz im Einsatz ich finde das Ding viel
zu krank
das ist viel zu geil das ist einfach zu
mächtig das Ding
[Musik]
ist ja voll stabil es gibt jetzt noch
ein Problem das ist schon mega geil
allerdings
120 Kilo Nägel noch drin und dann machen
wir das mal im Maßstab ja also dann
drückt man hier irgendwas rein hatten
Abdruck so irgendwann so
und dann sind das Problem ist du kannst
ja nicht einfach dieses riesen Gerät
das hat 150 km bewegt einfach einmal ja
kann man schon wenn man gestellt baut
und das Bauen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Mittelsäule und dann erkennt das von der
alten mittelalterlichen Konstruktion bzw
Seitenstreben
also das sieht echt krass nach
Mittelalter Foltermethode aus
jetzt weiß werden um die sich dann das
ganze dreht dafür schraube ich mir jetzt
den Kollegen da rein
[Musik]
ja und das wird jetzt erstmal
stabil
[Musik]
[Applaus]
oha
irgendwas
easy drehen damit unsere XXL Nagelbild
möglichst genau wie ein echtes aussieht
wird es jetzt noch mit dunkelgrauer
Farbe eingestrichen
[Musik]
sind jetzt erstmal ist die erste Packung
von 5 mit 25 Kilo Nägeln was glaubst Du
lange brauchen also schon so eine halbe
Stunde wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
rein Bruder
700 was ist er denn
Alter
überhaupt nicht
[Musik]
ja also eigentlich los
bisschen belastend
[Musik]
kommt zu mir hat er gesagt das wird
abwechslungsreich
[Musik]
aus
angenehm
geil
[Musik]
[Applaus]
voll angenehm ich muss ein bisschen
aufpassen dass ich gleichmäßig ist schon
ja es ist schon nicht so einfach man
muss sich da so nachvollziehen
so wild aus
das ist so geil okay
[Musik]
du würdest echt vorbohren ja dann würde
ich mit dem Zweier
[Musik]
okay jetzt kommen die Schrumpfschläuche
auch einfach 1700 mal
sind jetzt ein paar hier drauf deswegen
stelle ich jetzt den Kollegen mal auf
600 Grad und Schrumpf jetzt auf einmal
geil
ja es funktioniert halt nicht so geil
muss halt jeden einzeln machen und
dadurch
die volle Einweihung es ist einmal
umgefallen
der muss nicht drüber reden
[Applaus]
rückwärts an
so
geil ich finde das lustige
[Musik]
mit der Hand einfach dadurch dass hier
einfach die Hände quasi als Fortführung
von dieser Figur da sind sieht das
richtig gruselig aus
du hast gerade nochmal richtig guten
Bauch reingemacht also jetzt ohne Gas
ist schon deutlich geiler aus das muss
man sagen okay und let's go
ich hoffe das so geil wie wir es
vermuten wir werden und damit ist es
geschafft das Teil hier in XXL und auch
eins wo meine Hand endlich mal ganz
drauf passt das war's damit auch von dem
Video den Link zur Steuerbord wo ihr im
Schnitt 1.95 € für den Steuern zurück
bekommt gibt's in der Videobeschreibung
und ich bin damit raus macht's